peu importe la taille du sexe on apprend
pas à conduire en regardant en face and
Furious donc on n'apprend pas à faire
l'amour en gardant du porno
et on se dit [__] on va casser la
table cinéma qui est réservait aux
adultes et uniquement aux adultes si
nous avons pas envie en sorte de faire
l'amour nous ne faisons pas l'amour
c'est quoi du bordeaux
les coulisses du métier d'actory x la
réalité des tournages les difficultés
les salaires ou encore les secrets du
l'industrie massive mais finalement peu
connu salut c'est Hugo on se retrouve
aujourd'hui pour le sixième épisode de
notre série consacré à la découverte de
métiers particuliers on a déjà reçu
François Hollande ancien président de la
République l'astronaute Thomas Pesquet
ou encore Christophe coppen ancien
négociateur du raid aujourd'hui vous
l'aurez compris changement d'univers ce
sont deux acteurs de films pour adultes
anapolina et Rico Simons qui vont
répondre à nos questions même les plus
indiscrètes alors sur ces vidéos vous
plaisent vous pouvez vous abonner
bienvenue à tous les nouveaux et je vous
laisse tout de suite avec leurs réponses
comment avez-vous commencé à exercer ce
métier j'avais un attrait pour les
femmes les filles de joie en règle
générale dans la littérature dans le
cinéma il y avait une actrice qui
s'appelait Mélissa Loren je l'ai vu
comme une superwoman je l'ai trouvé
extrêmement pertinente j'ai trouvé que
ça voit était envoûtante que sa présence
était forte et je me suis dit elle baise
des mecs elle baise des nanas elle
s'éclate elle ne s'excuse pas pour ça et
ça m'avait fait une très forte
impression un an ou deux plus tard je
suis tombée sur King Kong Théorie Virgin
Despentes qui parle très bien de sujet
dans le chapitre porno sorcières et ça
ça a tourné dans ma tête et avec la
candeur de mes 19 ans je me suis dit et
pourquoi pas moi je vais essayer
j'écoutais beaucoup les les cours de
Michel Onfray il parlait souvent des
possibilités du corps et le fait de
pouvoir apprendre à se connaître à
travers des expériences évidemment
j'avais un attrait pour pour le sexe il
vaut mieux en avoir un pour ce métier là
et je me suis dit mais pourquoi pas
essayer de d'apprendre à me connaître à
travers à travers par ce biais j'ai eu
l'opportunité de faire un tournage et ça
c'est très bien passé est-ce que
n'importe qui peut devenir acteur ou
actrice clairement non enfin c'est très
très différent pour pour une actrice et
pour un acteur le cœur même en tout cas
de du porno en tout cas quand il y a un
acteur c'est d'avoir la possibilité
d'avoir une érection en continu et de
pas être déstabilisé par
par le contexte par l'équipe parce qu'on
nous demande parce que on va parfois
nous demander de faire des des choses
dans des contextes des situations
inhabituelles qui peut qui peuvent être
déstabilisantes donc il faut savoir
garder son calme il faut savoir rester
concentré et ça c'est vraiment vraiment
pas donné à tout le monde il faut être
comme je le dis extrêmement à l'aise
avec sa sexualité le faire dans des
bonnes conditions être parfaitement
encadré savoir peu importe que la raison
se soit le cul l'argent la gloire
on ne juge pas mais il faut avoir la
raison de base et il faut pas que ce
soit une raison qui soit destructrice
parce que si de base elle est
destructrice ça n'amènera pas à quelque
chose de bon donc ce n'est pas non plus
fait pour toutes les femmes il faut
avoir toujours en tête qu'ensuite il va
falloir gérer le fait qu'on soit vu par
des millions de gens et ça
toutes les personnes qui veulent faire
ça ou qu'on l'intention de le faire
n'ont pas forcément conscience comment
est-ce que vous préparez pour un
tournage je dirais dans un premier temps
que tout dépend du tournage si nous
sommes sur un film scénarisé avec du
texte si on me demande de ramener des
tenues aussi qui sont à nous de faire
par moments des UV ou bien d'avoir une
certaine manipule ou on va commencer à
préparer ça en amont on va commencer à
apprendre le texte parce que oui il y a
des films X des scénarios ensuite on va
aussi proposer nos tenues à la réa à la
styliste à l'assistante de la réa pour
créer un petit peu ce personnage et
ensuite il y a le moment où on vient sur
le tournage donc chacun fait comme il
veut personnellement moi j'essaie de
venir en forme et de vraiment faire en
sorte d'avoir dormi le plus possible et
ensuite via une autre préparation qui
est purement physique à savoir faire ces
tests donc avoir des tests de moins de
14 jours qui soit clean donc négatif
ensuite il y aura la douche l'hygiène
intime pour moi en tant que femme qui
fait de l'anal je vais aussi préparer
l'anal avec un plug du lubrifiant si je
suis proche du partenaire on peut couper
la scène avant le début de la nalle et
je peux demander à mon partenaire aussi
de m'aider d'aller un petit peu
doucement donc quand on voit par moments
des scènes coupées
dans les films X
qu'on voit la pénétration assez intense
en ce qui me concerne très souvent il y
a une préparation qui a été faite avant
quelle est la fréquence des tests pour
les infections sexuellement
transmissibles on fait des tests tous
les 15 jours et des tests assez complets
assez poussés on fait très très
attention à ça c'est c'est même la base
les productions ne payent pas les tests
c'est aux comédienne et comédiens de
prendre en charge ça des fois dans une
même semaine on travaille pour plusieurs
productions en même temps donc qui doit
payer combien de temps dure le tournage
d'une scène on va dire s'il y a juste du
sexe normalement en théorie une heure
une heure et demie c'est fait on est
d'accord
si on veut choisir dans les roches après
au montage alors il faut il faut aussi
ajouter un truc c'est que durant ce
temps là on n'est pas en action pendant
une heure non il faut il faut être clair
c'est que c'est peut-être d'autant plus
difficile on coupe régulièrement parce
que il faut on fait un plan large parce
que on fait un plan serré parce que on
fait des gros plans et que tout ça bah
ça nécessite de parfois de couper on
tombe pas forcément avec quatre caméras
en même temps des fois il y en a qu'une
il faut tout faire avec une caméra donc
on est obligé de couper on est obligé de
changer de position donc
ça implique encore une fois moi pour le
côté acteur homme bah il faut rester
concentré pendant tout ce temps là et
c'est pas forcément évident combien de
scènes tournez-vous par mois alors la
fréquence des tournages bah après ça
dépend des périodes je pense que c'est
comme tous les comme tous les artistes
il y a des périodes de creux et il y a
des périodes où c'est intense enfin ça
dépend moi ça ça m'est arrivé aussi de
d'avoir un refusé parce que je pouvais
pas faire 5 scènes dans la semaine au
bout d'un moment c'est c'est super
fatiguant mais ça peut ça peut être ça
ça peut être 3 4 5 scène bon maintenant
il faut dire STOP mais il y a des
périodes où genre pendant une semaine ou
deux bah il y a il y a rien mais bon
faut savoir l'accepter et puis des fois
ça reprend il y a des vagues moi ce qui
me concerne c'est vrai que sur plusieurs
années mon expérience elle a été très
différente quand au tout début je
tournais que comme une jeune proamate
qui voulait simplement s'amuser alors là
clairement c'est tant qu'ils étaient
sympas ah bah j'arrive ah bah j'arrive
ah mais je sens le tournage non mais
c'est pas grave je viendrai demain sur
le tien j'avais vraiment ce côté très
plein de candeurs et j'étais super
contente de venir et ensuite quand je me
suis professionnalisée je tournais
vraiment j'avais un certain nombre de
films à faire et donc j'ai déjà commencé
à tourner beaucoup beaucoup moins puis
par la suite j'ai quasiment arrêté de
tourner je ne tournais qu'avec mon
copain de l'époque et à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui je n'accepte que certaines
propositions qui m'intéressent
réellement parce que l'image me plaît
parce que j'aime bien la boîte de
production pour parce qu'ils acceptent
mon cachet aussi ça ça rentre en compte
pour toutes ces raisons là mais en
parallèle je fais des tournages pour mes
plateformes
et en revanche des tournages pour mes
plateformes j'en fais quand même un
minimum
à 0 - 7 jours 10 jours par mois est-ce
que vous prenez réellement du plaisir
quand vous tournez ah mais tout début je
t'ai aussi à une jeune femme de 19 ans
je ne connaissais pas certaines
pratiques je ne connaissais peut-être
pas assez bien mon corps donc je prenais
très facilement du plaisir et j'oubliais
complètement la caméra c'est à dire que
je me faisais plaisir à moi je
découvrais un acteur une actrice et je
m'en fichais complètement comment la
caméra me trouve comment je fais du
bruit ou pas et ça a été vraiment une
quête de plaisir à ce moment-là ensuite
il y a le moment on se professionnalise
un petit peu il y a le fait qu'il y a
des acteurs qu'on connaît depuis très
très longtemps donc ça quand on tourne
ensemble depuis 10 ans on va pas non
plus dire qu'on est dans le couple voilà
c'est ça on est
voilà tu as joué mon mari 40 fois bon
bah c'est ok donc oui on n'aura pas le
même désir la même qu'avec un nouvel
acteur une nouvelle actrice et ensuite
il y a une autre chose qui rentre en
compte c'est le réa c'est à dire qu'un
réa qui s'est passé donc il va vraiment
suivre un peu l'action
doucement dire à challenge position
enfin changer de position etc etc on va
être plus à même de l'oublier et de
vraiment prendre du plaisir lorsqu'on
fait une scène qui est constamment
coupée coupée pour changer la lumière
pour changer
l'axe parce que ceci parce que cela est
que c'est pas confortable et qu'on est
en train de se casser la gueule de la
banquette et on se dit [__] on va
casser la table je peu importe dans ces
moments là non clairement je ne il y a
pas d'orgasme en tant qu'acteur ben la
plupart du temps on nous demande quand
même d'avoir une éjaculation donc il
faut savoir rester concentré et
y aller chercher
au fin fond de soi les ressources pour
pour pouvoir éjaculer et c'est et c'est
très mental est-ce que vous ressentez
une pression sur votre apparence
physique ce n'est pas le porno ou des
réalisateurs qui m'ont fait me sentir
pas comme il faut avoir tel ou tel
défaut dans le X c'est quand même le
premier endroit où j'ai vu aussi bizarre
des filles complètement qui ont qui
allaient recours à la chirurgie des
pieds à la tête qu'au défi extrêmement
naturel avec des petits seins etc etc et
que ces filles là on les prenait dans
les mêmes productions en disant tu es
belle tu es belle comme tu es parce que
dans ton dans ton mood tu es belle ça
veut pas dire que la blonde super signe
plaira tout le monde ça veut pas dire
que la brune pulpeuse plaira tout le
monde ça veut juste dire beautiful
et il faut continuer à répéter au nanas
et moi dans ce contexte là le porno m'a
plus aidé qu'autre chose de plus en plus
de projets et d'ailleurs souvent qui
viennent de femmes qui veulent montrer
des corps qu'on n'a pas forcément
l'habitude de voir et moi je trouve ça
je trouve ça génial en fait j'ai accepté
beaucoup de ces de ces projets là parce
que je trouvais ça intéressant de
montrer d'autres choses tout simplement
moi j'ai pas un corps de golgot et j'ai
réussi à trouver ma place pendant des
années parce que il y avait besoin aussi
de cette diversité il y a oui il y a
forcément il y a des acteurs qui sont
plus grands plus musclés que moi mais il
répondent aussi un besoin et moi je
j'étais là aussi pour faire un peu le le
Game nextdor et je l'ai fait enfin bon
en même temps j'ai joué à peu près tous
les rôles possibles imaginable j'ai même
fait les gardes du corps ça veut dire
truc pas crédible du tout mais c'est
super important et je trouve ça bien
qu'il y ait une nouvelle générations de
réalisatrices réalisateur qui dit voilà
il faut il faut qu'il y ait plus de plus
de diversité dans les types de corps que
qu'on montre et de pas imposer de du
Nord du corps comment est-ce que votre
entourage perçoit votre métier il y a eu
une petite étude au début parce que
j'étais très vite repéré par la famille
et enfin j'avais eu quand même pris soin
d'en parler à certains proches et en
fait une fois qu'on explique qu'on est
dans un cadre qui est très pro que tout
est très bien encadré qu'on travaillait
avec des gens sérieux on voit qu'on
s'épanouit aussi parce que il y a ça
aussi ben les la famille l'accepte ou
les proches l'accepte je crois pas avoir
eu de proches qui se soit éloigné de moi
parce que je faisais ce métier là
lorsque j'ai commencé à faire du X mais
ami autour de moi trouver ça presque
drôle parce que il s'agissait un petit
peu d'aventure ils avaient une grande
curiosité pour mon activité néanmoins
mon meilleur ami m'a accompagné sur mon
premier tournage il abuse vérifier que
tout se passe bien donc j'ai été bien
soutenu aussi et le moment où c'est
devenu plus compliqué c'est lorsque j'ai
décidé d'en faire un métier donc c'est à
dire en gros le ah c'est ma copine anal
fait ça ça et c'est quoi tu pardon
c'était un peu waouh mais lorsque je dis
non je veux vraiment faire ça ce sera
mon métier c'est comme ça là les gens
ont eu un petit temps adaptation moi
j'entends très bien et je comprends que
qu'un parent n'est pas forcément envie
que sa fille fasse du porno je je je
peux l'accepter et je pense aussi qu'on
peut aimer les gens sans pour autant
être fan de ce qu'ils font je pense que
c'est c'est totalement
compatible on n'est pas obligé de
rejeter mais on n'est pas obligé
d'approuver à 100%
en tout cas lorsque les gens nous aiment
généralement ils se montrent
bienveillants et c'est ce que j'ai
constaté autour de moi les personnes qui
m'aiment sont toujours extrêmement
bienveillantes à mon égard et dans ma
vie
personnelle amoureuse en toute franchise
ça ne pose pas vraiment de problème en
revanche j'accepte de faire des
arrangements puisque nous sommes deux si
la personne me dit attend écoute là tu
as sur ce tournage je suis pas sûr
d'aimer le contenu de ce site ou de
telles choses est-ce qu'on peut en
discuter ça je suis totalement ouverte
ça que c'est pas non plus je décide de
tout tu as rien à me dire c'est un entre
deux est-ce difficile d'être en couple
lorsque vous êtes acteur ou actrice X
lorsque je suis chez moi avec mon
amoureux nous n'avons pas de caméra
autour de nous nous n'avons pas tant de
position à faire nous ne sommes pas
obligés de faire l'amour d'ailleurs si
nous avons pas envie en sorte de faire
l'amour nous ne faisons pas l'amour
première chose deuxième chose
j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur une forme de
confiance
et à savoir
d'être ok avec ça moi je suis dans une
relation qui est quand même exclusive il
y a une différence entre le pro ou
vraiment je fais mes tournages et le
perso lorsque je suis avec mon
partenaire et enfin il y a aussi autre
chose c'est que les certaines personnes
s'imaginent qu'une actrice X baisse du
matin au soir du matin au soir et comme
ça tous les jours
la réalité des faits c'est que je
tourne comme je l'ai dit on va dire sept
jours par mois maximum si je compte les
tournages et les plateformes donc une
ciné ça représente pas la majorité de
mes journées comment voyez-vous le
rapport ou les tensions entre les films
pornographiques et la question de
l'éducation sexuelle c'est du cinéma X
cinéma qui est réservé aux adultes et
uniquement aux adultes la loi elle est
très claire là-dessus la mise à
disposition elle est répréhensible il
devrait pas y avoir de débat
le cinéma les films X c'est pour les
adultes point barre c'est pas c'est pas
là pour faire l'éducation sexuelle des
enfants il y a les parents qui sont là
pour ça il y a l'éducation nationale il
y a il y a peut-être d'autres
institutions mais le porno il est pas là
pour ça le porno c'est du divertissement
on apprend pas à conduire en regardant
en face and Furious donc on apprend pas
à faire l'amour en gardant du porno mais
le problème se trouve dans le fait que
il n'y ait pas beaucoup de référentiel
sexuel les parents ne sont pas toujours
à l'aise avec ça ils n'ont pas toujours
été formés à ça l'école je crois que les
cours d'éducation sexuelle en tout cas
moi de ce que j'ai connu à mon époque ce
résumait à mettait un préservatif sinon
vous aurez des maladies et c'est déjà ça
parce que du coup j'ai mis des capotes
donc quelque part c'est rentré ça m'a
déjà préservé de ça ensuite c'est très
rare il y en a dans quelques écoles
quelques moments des intervenants
extérieurs qui viennent un petit peu
parler de la pornographie on nous accuse
nous constamment de de donner le mauvais
exemple alors que nous nous ne sommes
pas là pour ça nous sommes là pour
apporter du plaisir et comme la di Rico
nous sommes des adultes qui faisons du
contenu pour les adultes quel est le
salaire d'un acteur ou d'une actrice X
ça dépend de l'expérience qu'on a
l'idéal c'est quand même d'avoir un
cachet enfin en tout cas un tarif fixe
et d'ailleurs c'est souvent ce qui se
passe que ce soit pour les pour les
actrices comme pour les acteurs il y a
un salaire fixe alors pour les acteurs
ça dépend de la notoriété qu'on a il y
en a certains ça peut monter jusqu'à
plusieurs milliers de dollars la scène
mais ça reste des exceptions on est
plutôt sur des sur des centaines que sur
des milliers après c'est un métier où il
faut le reconnaître les actrices sont
mieux payées sont beaucoup mieux payés
que les hommes parce que c'est vrai que
le cinéma X repose beaucoup sur l'image
de la femme qui est mise en avant donc
moi je trouve ça tout à fait légitime
que les
même si on travaille aussi beaucoup en
tant qu'acteur mais je trouve ça
légitime que les que les femmes puissent
puisse toucher plus et puis enfin voilà
c'est bien aussi qu'un métier où les
femmes puissent toucher plus en soi ça
ne me pose pas de problème et les femmes
ça va aussi être en fonction des
pratiques starcelles solo le fille
garçon fille garçon
Lana le pénétration et en fonction de ça
elles peuvent augmenter le tarif et ça
c'est vraiment en fonction de la fille
à combien elle va
qu'elle est quelle sera la différence en
fait je pense que c'est aussi une
question de il y a des jeunes filles qui
arrivent et qui vont demander justement
des cachets bien plus important alors
qu'à mon époque puisque tu étais
nouvelle tu avais demandé un cachet
moins important donc ça aussi pas mal
changer là-dessus et pour moi dans le
bon sens ça peut commencer oui avec
quelques centaines
d'euros et ça peut grimper sur quelques
milliers mais pareil c'est des cas mais
vraiment vraiment à part c'est quelques
filles et c'est très rare que
pensez-vous des plateformes comme ou
encore MIM alors en toute franchise j'ai
mis beaucoup de temps à me mettre sur
les plateformes puissent qu'au début
peut-être que je procrastinais un petit
peu que je me disais oh je sais pas si
je suis capable de produire un bon
contenu et la première fois que j'ai
ouvert un de mes comptes de plateforme
je me disais mais non c'est pas assez
bizarre le contenu n'est pas assez bon
et finalement des personnes m'ont
rejointes des personnes extrêmement
bienveillantes et ça c'est vraiment le
plaisir des plateformes c'est que la
plupart du temps à 99% sont quand même
des personnes qui envoient beaucoup de
messages de soutien d'encouragement qui
viennent pour être excitées et qui
viennent vraiment pour le plaisir mais
aussi pour échanger avec nous petit à
petit je me suis libéré j'ai appris de
nouvelles pratiques comme le Dolce
et j'adore ça c'est ce qui m'éclate le
plus aujourd'hui et j'en fais beaucoup
et ils sont en tout cas mes abonnés ont
l'air d'apprécier ça j'aime le contact
direct avec eux le fait de pouvoir leur
proposer aussi des vidéos personnalisées
des photos personnalisées de leur parler
en direct de donner des conseils ils ont
envie et certains sont vraiment devenus
comme des
presque comme des amis ça peut paraître
étrange mais c'est une réalité ensuite
c'est intéressant de tourner pour
soi-même parce que justement on n'a pas
à dire ça doit durer de temps on décide
et par moment moi je préfère faire 12
minutes où je suis réellement excitée où
je me donne vraiment à fond avec la
tenue qui me plaît l'éclairage qui me
plaît plutôt que de tourner deux heures
trois heures et finalement de pas être
fan de ce que je fais combien
gagnez-vous via ces plateformes pour
pour ça c'est je préfère ne pas donner
de chiffres mais les plateformes oui ça
peut aller ça peut être moyen ça peut
aller très haut ça dépend puis faut
savoir par contre une chose très
particulière on peut faire un très bon
mois à un moment donné et faire un mois
tout pourri enfin beaucoup moins bon le
d'après c'est que c'est là où la
plateforme ça te challenge constamment
il suffit pas d'avoir des abonnés il
faut garder ses abonnés et leur donner
quelque chose d'intéressant qu'en est-il
de la précarité dans ce métier je n'ai
pas une visio globale de tout mais j'ai
l'impression que comme toujours il y a
toujours eu la webcam il y a les salons
de l'érotisme il y a les plateformes
donc ça la plateforme c'est nouveau mais
sans les autisme et la webcam c'est là
depuis longtemps ce type de travail il y
a toujours des parallèles tout comme le
strip-tease il y a toujours des
parallèles pour pour continuer à générer
un certain revenu et aujourd'hui avec
les plateformes je pense que en
s'investissant il est possible de
justement au contraire bien s'en sortir
en revanche peut-être qu'il y a aussi
moins de production peut-être qu'il y a
moins de films scénarisés peut-être
qu'il y a moins de place pour ça mais je
pense pas que ça soit un métier qui
précarise tant que ça non plus je pense
qu'en revanche il y a peut-être des
productions qui peuvent éventuellement
profiter de la naïveté de certaines
filles qui débutent leur faire miroiter
un salaire qui en fait est dérisoire
mais sinon je pense que une fille qui
trouve sa voix et elle arrive à imposer
son salaire enfin son cachet elle arrive
à imposer un cachet qui sera correct ce
qui est dommage c'est que une fille ou
même un garçon mais surtout une fille
qui débute ne sait pas par où commencer
et il y a peut tomber dans des choses
trap tomber aux mauvais aux mauvais
endroit ça peut arriver on sait que
c'est arrivé dernièrement on pourra
peut-être en reparler et ça c'est c'est
dommage c'est pour ça qu'il faudrait
pouvoir communiquer là-dessus il
faudrait pouvoir faire en sorte qu'il y
ait un cadre qu'on puisse les renseigner
et leur dire c'est un salaire enfin
cachet c'est de temps à temps il faut
travailler que tel production oui oui
avec ça avec cette personne non il ne
faut pas mais il y a pas ça en fait
quand quand on débarque et c'est un peu
dommage alors là dessus bon moi je
trouve qu'il y a quand même avoir grand
changement lorsque il y a eu une charte
de déontologie qui est qui est sorti
alors ça me semblait important de faire
un petit point rapide ici cette charte
de déontologie dont parle anapolina
c'est un texte qui a été publié il y a 2
ans par la société de production Marc
Dorcel et élaboré par une ex actrice X
Lisa Del Sierra un sociologue et un
avocat concrètement dans cette charte on
retrouve 18 recommandations à proposer à
tous les producteurs de films pour
adultes pour que les tournages soient
plus responsables et respectent tout
simplement la loi parmi elles le fait
que toutes les scènes de sexe sont
définies à l'avance par le contrat
qu'aucune pression ne devrait être
exercée sur les acteurs et actrices pour
obtenir leur consentement ou encore
qu'aucune actrice ou acteur ne pourrait
être forcée à tourner sans préservatif
cependant il faut noter que les
productions n'ont aucune obligation à
l'appliquer c'est quand même une charte
qui est jusque là en tout cas de tout ce
que j'ai vu a été vraiment appliqué ça
permet aux filles justement d'avoir un
accueil d'assister en tournage avant de
tourner elle-même d'être mieux informé
aujourd'hui aussi dans une médias je
vois plus d'intervenantes de figures du
x qui qui en parle donc aujourd'hui on
sait plus faire on est quand même mieux
renseigné qu'à mon époque sur quel
statut on peut peut-être adopter il y a
quand même beaucoup plus de je trouve
que c'est beaucoup moins sombre c'est
charte bon bah elles ont entre
guillemets le mérite d'exister mais sont
quand même arrivé très très tard et sont
arrivés suite à des affaires
où ça aurait pu être anticipé pour cette
dernière question on a voulu évoquer
avec Anna et Rico des événements qui ont
fait l'actualité ces derniers mois dans
le milieu du porno le premier c'est la
mise en examen de 18 personnes
travaillant dans l'industrie des films
pour adultes pour viol proxénétisme et
traite d’être humain en 2021 parmi eux
il y a notamment le producteur et acteur
Pascal op il est accusé d'avoir profité
de la naïveté et de la détresse de
nombreuses femmes pour les faire tourner
dans des films pornographiques il est
aussi accusé de les avoir contraints à
certaines pratiques auxquelles elle
n'était pas consentante pendant les
tournages la deuxième actualité qui fait
suite donc assez révélations c'est un
rapport du Sénat dans les dérives de
l'industrie du porno qui a été intitulé
l'enfer du décor et qui a été publié le
28 septembre 2022 il a été rédigé par
quatre sénatrices françaises et a
nécessité six mois de travaux dedans on
apprend que les dizaines de femmes ont
subi des pressions voire même dans
certains cas des viols de la part de
certains réalisateurs producteurs ou
acteurs que leur consentement n'a pas
toujours été respecté en résumé dans
plusieurs cas on est dans une zone de
non-droit avec des principes certes
théoriques mais qui ne sont pas
respectées dans les faits ça nous
semblait donc intéressant d'avoir le
regard de certains professionnels du
secteur sur des dérives existantes
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous avez déjà eu
des mauvaises expériences la plupart des
enfin je dirais très vaste majorité des
tournages que j'ai fait il y a jamais eu
aucun problème il peut y avoir des
querelles entre comédiens des
comédiennes des réalisateurs etc ça ça
arrive mais je veux dire ça arrive dans
le monde du travail aussi d'avoir des
conflits par contre ce genre de cas où
il y a eu des viols ou en effet il y a
eu un système qui a été mis en place par
un par un producteur moi j'ai jamais vu
ça enfin je sais pas pour ça j'ai jamais
j'ai jamais assisté à ça de ma vie de
toute ma carrière ce qui ce qui fait que
ça arrive aujourd'hui c'est que ça a été
maintenu secret pendant très longtemps
d'aucun diront que tout le monde était
au courant ce qui me fait doucement
rigoler les personnes qui avaient mis
système en place on fait en sorte qu'il
reste caché le plus longtemps possible
les filles qui tournaient dans ces
scènes là on ne les voyait jamais
justement parce que il savait très bien
que ce qu'il faisait c'était quelque
chose d'extrêmement grave ils ont fait
en sorte que c'est fixe ne puissent pas
avoir de contact avec le reste du métier
pour qu'elle ne puisse pas en parler
pour qu'elle ne puisse pas dénoncer ce
qu'elles avaient vécu je n'ai jamais
assisté à aux choses que que j'ai lu aux
choses qui m'ont été rapportées et
effectivement je pense que c'est ces
choses odieuses qui se sont produites
par des personnes criminelles et des
viandes ne doivent surtout pas
représenter toutes les personnes qui
font ce métier avec passion avec amour
et avec respect pour les acteurs les
actrices les techniciens et vraiment
c'est c'est terrible c'est terrible
d'être associé à ça parce que
on est vraiment dans quelque chose de
ben je me permets de dire c'est
criminels on est plus dans le délire
dans quelque chose de criminel tandis
que nous on fait simplement on exerce un
métier subversif donc entre subversif
d'adultes avec adultes consentant pour
des adultes consentants n'a aucun
rapport avec criminel et être associé à
ça c'est juste terrible si je peux dire
un mot de du rapport qui était fourni
par des sénatrices j'aimerais juste dire
que c'est une pavoste blague très
mauvaise blague je l'ai parcouru on lit
quelque chose dans la conclusion était
déjà écrite avant même qu'il y ait des
interviews qui étaient faites ça se voit
un rapport parlementaire du Sénat qui
dès le début annonce la couleur en
disant l'enfer du décor je crois c'est
juste pas sérieux enfin il y a des
actrices qui ont été interviewées
systématiquement dans tout le rapport
toutes les disposition qu'elles font
elles sont minimisées elles sont
dénigrées tout au long du rapport on ne
met en avant que les problèmes et jamais
les solutions ou ce qui va bien tout ça
me lance qui va bien la grande majorité
de ce qui se passe dans ce métier se
déroule très bien il y a aucun souci et
là on essaye de faire d'un cas une
généralité c'est un cas qui est
dramatique c'est sa mauvaise promotion
pour notre métier mais c'est encore une
fois pas du tout du tout représentatif
de ce qui se passe au jour le jour
vraiment pas merci d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo je sais que ça change des sujets
qu'on a à l'occasion de traiter au
quotidien mais aussi vous proposer
d'autres thématiques qu'on peut aborder
merci à Blanche journaliste au sein de
l'équipe qui a préparé et mené cette
interview il y a Anna et Rico d'avoir
accepté aussi de répondre à nos
questions prenez soin de vous et on se
dit à bientôt